[Waves crashing]
The mighty song of the ocean.
Beneath the waves, the story of a young whale’s
astonishing voyage across uncharted waters
is about to begin.
But this is not Earth’s ocean, nor is this
an Earth whale.
This is the saga of “South Scrimshaw,”
a game-documentary hybrid created by the brilliant
Nathan O. Marsh.
In this video, we’ll follow the young whale’s
odyssey through the alien ocean depths, and
discover a tale of loss, and deep connections.
And you can play the full game yourself and
support the artist using the links below.
Now, the sea is calling…
The journey of a lifetime begins in the comforting
warmth of an aquatic egg.
A newborn mind is getting their very first
look at sunlight through the membrane of their
sanctuary.
This is a male whale calf — not the sort
of creature one might expect to find incubating
inside an egg.
But this is no ordinary egg, and this is no
ordinary calf.
And his extraordinary life is about to start.
A thunderous call reverberates from the unknown
world beyond the egg, shaking the calf to
his core.
Yet the calf isn’t frightened.
He recognizes the call as his mother’s.
Instincts tell him to stretch his new body
for the first time, pushing against the membrane
of the egg.
A seam begins to open.
Just one more impressive stretch, and the
only world he’s ever known opens into a
blinding light!
Warm, tropical shallows flourish on the other
side of the egg.
To be completely technical, this is not an
‘egg’ as we’d understand it, but a kind
of external womb that local scientists call
a “birthing shell.”
Like most mammals on our planet, the whales
we know give live birth.
But we are no longer on our planet.
At last, the calf enters the teeming waters.
A bewildering array of life overwhelms his
delicate senses.
Tiny fish waste no time in gobbling flecks
of nutrients.
Foliage seem to react to our calf’s presence,
clinging to him like they have a mind of their
own.
Even with his mother’s reassuring call,
this is all too much for the calf.
He swims downwards, passing bizarre sponges
and crustaceans that dwell amidst the fronds.
Something gently puts a stop to his panicked
dive.
Our calf is being carried to the surface.
The upward motion is tender, like the steady
movements of a cradle.
The young whale has no idea what to make of
any of this.
At last, he breaches, and enjoys his first
critical breath of air.
Like earth whales, he can’t breathe underwater,
and might have drowned without intervention.
Now, the calf finds himself in an empty expanse.
In an ordinary season, this region would be
filled with whales just like himself.
Instead, the surface is woefully empty — with
the unusual exception of a large mass of plants.
Our calf stares at the peculiar island.
The plant fronds continue to tenderly grasp
at him.
None of his instincts are any help.
Something moves atop the heap of plant matter.
What is it?
[bird call] Nothing good, the infant decides.
The surface world is much too strange.
Diving back under the surface, the poor calf
is overwhelmed with fear and hunger.
He knows he needs to nurse, but can’t locate
his mother.
The plants ensnare him once again, as if detecting
helplessness.
But though only minutes old, our calf is still
able to fight for survival, biting the vines.
His mother’s comforting call makes him stop.
The remarkable truth finally dawns on our
calf.
The mass of foliage is his mother, and she
has been with him all along.
She is a Brillo Whale at a remarkable later
stage of life — a window into the calf’s
astonishing future.
A suspicious pile of rock lies on the sandy
floor of the Brillo breeding grounds.
This warrants a closer investigation.
Time for a deep scan.
Just as we suspected — it’s a Stonedog.
This unique animal lives in a shell of scavenged
material, much like the nomadic hermit crabs
of Earth’s beaches.
The Stonedog is trying to hide, but is it
a convincing form of camouflage?
The creature checks to make sure it hasn’t
been spotted.
Too late.
Our calf is looking for fun, not food, but
the Stonedog doesn’t know this.
Our calf has grown curious and rambunctious.
His tumultuous birth hasn’t hindered his
playfulness.
He enjoys lifting his fluke into the air —something
Earth whales do for a variety of reasons,
including showing off.
Light rain has begun to fall, a phenomenon
completely novel to the young calf.
A bellow from his mother reminds him not to
wander off.
Though eager for adventure, the little calf
is still much too anxious to leave her side.
He excitedly shows his mother what he found
exploring, by bumping it into her face.
The mother is trying to rest.
But her love for her son is stronger than
her weariness.
And this playing is not mere frivolity.
For cetaceans like whales and dolphins, play
is a vital part of cognitive development — serving
as important training for catching food.
But right now, there’s only one type of
food our whale calf cares about.
His mother’s milk will provide the nourishment
needed to grow a special layer of spongy tissue
that makes Brillo Whales so unique.
In adult Brillo Whales, this tissue acts as
a refuge for other organisms, allowing for
symbiosis beyond anything here on Earth.
The mother has chosen to bond with botanical
matter, and while she might appear overrun,
the truth is far more interesting.
Another deep scan will reveal how plant and
animal have merged to an extraordinary degree.
Unlike the stone dog, the foliage and small
animal life surrounding the mother whale’s
body aren’t just camouflage, but a way of
life.
Like a kind of living hotel, her body has
designated areas where other lifeforms can
take up residence, with a secondary layer
protecting her vitals from her many houseguests.
But this bizarre anatomy leaves us with more
questions than answers.
Most notably — what is the benefit of such
a peculiar system?
To help us visualize the explanation, we’ll
get a little help… from a seabunny, better
known as a seabun.
The seabun is a mascot that has long been
associated with this planet…
however, it is not a real animal, even in
this world.
The seabun myth originates from the early
days of planetary exploration, and was something
of an urban legend among the first scientists.
Over the years, the joke took on a life of
its own, with some people mistakenly believing
the seabun to be an actual animal.
Yet the seabun will serve as a helpful example
for why an organism might want to bond with
a whale.
Underwater locomotion is energy intensive,
and ‘carpooling’ with another lifeform
can be a great benefit.
Living on a huge whale also means predators
might think twice about getting close.
In return, some animals that partner with
Brillos will help them hunt for food.
Some Brillo partners will even feed directly
off the whales themselves, in return for some
sort of useful service.
It might sound like too strange a partnership
to emerge, but we can find analogous relationships
right here on Earth.
Oxpeckers are birds that clean parasites off
the side of large mammals.
During the process, the oxpecker skims a marginal
amount of the mammal’s blood as a sort of
nutritional bonus.
The large animals put up with this, as the
parasite removal service is worth the cost.
But Brillos have taken symbiosis to new extremes,
to the point where many partner species have
evolved specifically to live their lives around
the whales.
Sometimes, the two lifeforms become so interdependent
they’re difficult to tell apart — but
such cases are thankfully uncommon.
So, what kind of a relationship does the mother
have with her plants?
The answer has to do with photosynthesis.
On her own, the mother has no way of extracting
energy from the sun, but plants do it all
the time, and they share some of the sugars
they produce with their generous host.
The tradeoff is that she now must spend a
considerable amount of time near the surface,
where there’s enough sunlight for the plants
to grow.
Emerald Sea Slugs of Earth have a similar
partnership with algae that grows within their
bodies.
However, not all passengers are welcome.
This is a Blood Trilobite.
They aren’t here to pay their fair share.
The Blood Trilobite is a bandit, pilfering
from a vein with an extended proboscis.
Fortunately, the mother has a personal bodyguard.
The Vellum Worm has one duty in this ecosystem
— to remove uninvited guests.
It’s a busy job, as herbivores also seek
to feed on her many leaves.
A hungry fish thinks they’ve hit the jackpot.
They’re in for a rude awakening.
The Vellum Worm has a neurotoxin-dispensing
barb to make sure gatecrashers get the message.
The misfortunate fish stands little chance.
The Brillo Whale’s ecosystem is called a
‘Symbiotic Garden.’
But like much of the life on this planet,
these plants seem too Earth-like to have evolved
independently.
Just how did such life come to this alien
ocean?
That’s a question that will have to wait.
Right now, our calf has discovered his mother’s
plants are fun to play with — but she scolds
him.
Such behavior is currently too risky — for
the mother is quite unwell.
A sharp branch has punctured through her protective
layer.
These kinds of complications can merge in
Brillo Whales as they get older.
The thorns are in danger of injuring her intestines.
A sudden movement could mean the end.
The mother does not know how long she will
be around to protect her calf, and is determined
to reach the safety of the Brillo herd before
the situation worsens.
A long journey lies ahead of them, but for
now, mother and child take a moment to rest
together…
To understand the voyage ahead, let’s examine
a simplified map of the surrounding ocean.
The dark blue line represents an ocean fault,
which pushed up land from the sea, forming
the Chartreuse Archipelago.
The first human explorers named each island
in the chain, including ‘South Scrimshaw’
where this documentary gets its title.
Thus far, the mother and son have lived in
the safety of the nearby region of Phthalo
Bay.
But they have traveled all the way to here
— and are about to cross into dangerous
open ocean.
It is the dawn of a new day.
The mother swims under the surface, making
mysterious calls through the deep.
The calf returns from surfacing, retreating
to the safety of the bramble beneath his mother.
He doesn’t understand the purpose of her
calls, but he recognizes she is on alert — and
that the waters before them are deeper than
any he’s known.
A sound comes from the far distance.
It’s the call of another Brillo whale, approaching
their position.
Our calf is curious about the new arrival.
He spots a far-off speck, and watches it grow
steadily larger.
Even as the other whale gets closer, the calf
seems uncertain.
Something about this other whale isn’t right.
The calf retreats further into the bramble
nest.
The mother admonishes him in response, as
if encouraging him to be more neighborly.
His apprehension is understandable.
For this Brillo whale is in a clever disguise.
A false head is located on the creature’s
tail, in an attempt at mimicking a threatening
predator.
The Brillo has no way to construct such a
costume on its own — but this Brillo has
a unique symbiotic assistant.
A Weaverlobe.
These astute designers craft intimidating
attire for their whale mobile-homes to deter
attackers.
They spin the apparel from a material called
ossomer, a unique kind of long-chain polymer.
While the animal kingdom is full of clever
architects, it seems unlikely that a single
organism could create something so complex.
Instead, it is likely that a colony of Weaverlobes
worked together to craft the impressive camouflage.
In any case, this Brillo will be a powerful
ally for the coming journey.
And she is not alone.
Like our mother, she is looking to transport
her calf to safety.
Our calf still isn’t feeling very welcoming.
And he’s in for another surprise visitor.
A strange, rocky shape approaches from behind.
It’s another whale.
The armored Brillo is also a mother, and seems
to be suffering from an internal injury: only
able to produce short honks.
While the calf is uncomfortable, these traveling
companions will make for a safer crossing.
His mother nudges him from above.
It’s time to depart.
The deep ocean awaits.
Only fifty-seven kilometers now separate the
pod from the Great Southern Reef.
This final stage of the voyage takes them
over a treacherous abyssal trench, so the
mothers swim in defensive formation.
With just three adults, however, they cannot
completely protect their calves.
Our youngster has done an admirable job keeping
up with their hurried pace.
He too can sense there is no time to linger.
Something is out there.
A dark shadow has been following the pod since
the early afternoon.
Though it has yet to attack, the unknown pursuer
seems to be biding its time.
The calf no longer finds the other Brillos
quite so frightening.
To his left, the stony mother and her child
swim in a protective arrangement.
This calf seems just as uneasy as ours is.
The exterior of the stony mother has reduced
in size to become more streamlined, shrinking
via some unknown internal mechanism.
Even when in exposed waters, Brillos are full
of surprises.
Our calf doesn’t understand the stony mother’s
changed appearance.
He turns his attention to down below, where
the mimic mother swims with her calf.
Alongside a light from one of the documentary
crew’s drones.
Since the light has already interrupted the
shot, this seems like a natural moment to
discuss the technology used in the documentation
of Brillo whales.
The scientists who have come to this planet
primarily use repurposed drones in the filming
of wildlife.
The inner-workings of these drones are quite
sophisticated, allowing them to keep pace
with aquatic life without disrupting their
natural routines.
Returning to the scene, the mimic mother swims
upside down to prevent attacks from below.
She’s uneasy about her role in the formation,
as her disguise isn’t effective from this
angle.
Our calf seems concerned as well.
His mother reassures him with a hum.
He is safe with her.
But the shadow remains.
It’s a Penumbra Shark, the fastest predator
in this ocean.
It could close the gap between itself and
the whales at any time.
There’s no rush.
Like the lightning-fast sailfish of Earth’s
oceans, the Penumbra Shark possesses a mighty
dorsal fin.
They keep it withdrawn — until ready to
strike.
In an instant, the shark has vanished.
In a panic, the mothers break from their defensive
formation.
Our calf glances down — and sees nothing
but open ocean.
He is completely exposed to attack.
Instantaneously, adrenaline floods his system.
His brain goes into overdrive, now taking
in every horrible detail.
The monster’s teeth shine like stoplights
through the darkness.
Our calf cannot possibly escape in time.
But his mother has a strategy.
Tension resides in her thorny branches, that
can be released with whip-like speed.
One forceful snap, and her child is protected
in a fortification of brambles.
But the shark detects the shift - and changes
targets - to the stone mother’s calf - who
is woefully exposed.
Our calf looks on in horror.
The sight is nearly too traumatic to process.
It is only due to the vigilance of his mother
that our calf survived the encounter.
The safety of the reef and the other Brillos
are now very close.
The mimic mother pulls ahead of the pod.
The stone mother follows, disoriented and
in shock after losing her only child.
Our calf is falling further and further behind.
He does not wish to leave his mother, and
she is not keeping pace.
He swims back to her, trying to coax her to
continue.
But she is no longer moving.
Saving her calf came at the sacrifice of reopening
her preexisting injuries.
Not understanding, the child calls to his
mother as he has a hundred times before.
There is no response.
She has done all she can to protect her son,
but she can hold on no longer.
Still, our calf prods his mother to move.
At this age, our calf has no hope of surviving
alone without a mother’s milk and protection.
This could be the end…
…But another call echoes through the water.
The stone mother is circling back.
A new day begins on the Great Southern Reef.
The stone mother has arrived safely… and
she is not alone.
Our calf drinks its fill of milk, recovering
from the arduous journey.
It is a moving case of social adoption.
The stone mother’s exterior has now deflated
to the point where we can see she is a young
adult, quite small for her species.
She has rescued our orphaned calf from certain
doom, and perhaps the calf has rescued her
as well.
Physically and emotionally exhausted, the
new family gets some much-needed rest.
In the morning, they will wake to an entirely
new world.
Warm sunlight illuminates the coral of the
Great Reef.
An inquisitive Bikili fish picks through the
irregular terrain.
She’s hungry, and thinks she’s spotted
breakfast.
The minute eyes of Greebles peer from the
alcoves below.
The Bikili fish has her work cut out for her
trying to dig them out.
But before she can begin, she is rudely chased
off.
A larger hunter is throwing their weight around.
This is a spotted barnacle claw, and it will
have no trouble catching Greebles.
A single, forceful tug wrenches the entire
colony from the nooks below.
The host Brillo Whale isn’t satisfied with
its partner species’ choice of food.
It needs something a bit meatier.
Our young whale witnesses the unfamiliar spectacle
from a distance.
Even after some time living on the reef, there
is always something new to see.
The bellows of other Brillos reverberate through
the water.
Though many are strangers, there is at least
one familiar face.
Though her appearance has changed considerably,
his adoptive mother never strays too far away.
Many eye spots now disguise her exterior — likely
a response to the Penumbra shark attack.
And though he might not look it, our whale
has changed too.
His body has at last developed the necessary
tissue layer to bond with other species.
But what kind of adult will he become?
It’s the most important question in any
young Brillo’s life.
There are near unlimited combinations, and
the wrong choice can mean disaster.
A common strategy is to imitate successful
adults.
A young Brillo finds a prosperous grownup,
and attempts to follow in their footsteps.
Adults will sometimes take apprentice Brillos
under their flippers for multiple years, providing
them with the materials needed to complete
a transformation.
Not all body-plans are equally appealing.
This old veteran is welcoming, but our whale
isn’t sure it’s the career for him.
It’s an understandable feeling, although
another Brillo might be more open to the job
offer.
More than half of Brillos choose to replicate
their biological mothers, and our whale seems
intent on preserving her legacy.
This botanical mass is made of the same plants
his mother bonded with.
But this Brillo has long passed, and is now
nothing but an overgrown graveyard.
Though our whale cannot bond with the decayed
plants, they still hold a profound emotional
significance.
Our whale needs to bond soon, but is having
trouble finding a living plant-based Brillo.
There is one expectation — an adult with
a stunning cloak of foliage.
But despite repeated attempts from the youngster,
this adult doesn’t seem interested in taking
on an apprentice.
He is a lone male — a bachelor looking for
a mate, not a babysitting gig.
His latest attempt to find love is a dismal
failure.
She seems confused by his little shadow, who
yanks at his well-groomed coat.
It’s the final straw — our whale is no
longer welcome.
The intricacy of Brillo whale’s Symbiotic
Gardens is impressive, but not entirely unheard
of.
A single adult human can have over 39 trillion
microbial cells living inside their body at
a time.
Not just germs, these foreign microorganisms
play a vital role in our survival.
The Brillos just take this concept further
by integrating with macro-organisms.
There are numerous species our whale could
merge with, even if plants are off the menu.
This reef is a never-ending menagerie of life.
The reason for this abundance has to do with
the structure of the coral itself.
The Great Southern Reef is a fringing reef,
comprised of multiple layers.
Spire Coral is the reason for the unique structure.
This distinct species starts small, then grows
steadily until it becomes a towering mass
that other coral grows on top of.
With time, the central mass is smothered,
and the structure becomes over-encumbered.
The tower then shatters, collapsing, with
new Spire Coral growing from the fallen giant.
This endless cycle has created an environment
of innumerable ravines and hide-aways.
Organisms like saltwater tadpoles thrive in
this coral city, spending their early stages
safely hidden away, before emerging as mighty
carnivores.
Well, relatively mighty.
Time marches ever onwards.
Our young whale has seen many forms of adulthood,
some of which are completely baffling.
Once again, he isn’t interested.
One afternoon, his fortunes seem to turn when
an impressive hunting party reappears from
the wild.
The head of the pod calls to our youngster.
He doesn’t respond.
This adult is a brilliant huntsman, partnering
with the Chowper, a rather unintelligent shark
species who sees him as a pack member, and
follows his lead.
It’s an incredible strategy, and this adult
is ready to share the tricks of the trade.
But our whale still isn’t moving.
All his attention is on the Chowper.
His trauma is too severe to partner with a
shark species.
He flees.
Over the coming weeks, our whale’s mental
health continues to spiral.
It is crucial for his survival that he starts
symbiosis, but he’s too unwell to begin.
The agitated youth can sense that time is
short, but this stress is little help.
More adult Brillos come and go.
This camouflaged whale is one of the more
unique that has appeared on the reef.
It is covered in octopuses that have linked
themselves together — allowing them to instantly
change their colors in unison.
Octopuses in our oceans have similar color
shifting abilities, although they pale in
comparison to the color changing abilities
of their interplanetary counterparts.
But the time has come at last to answer the
question of why life on this planet seems
so similar to life on Earth.
One might assume the answer is convergent
evolution — a process by which different
species evolve analogous features due to comparable
evolutionary pressures.
But this answer is not sufficient.
The true reason why Brillo whales look so
much like Earth whales is that they share
a common ancestor.
English scientist Francis Crick is notable
not just for helping to discover the structure
of DNA, but for his theory of ‘Directed
Panspermia.’
This hypothesis holds that life on earth might
have sprung from ‘seeds’ spread by an
ancient interplanetary civilization.
While there is little evidence such a thing
happened on Earth, within this universe, such
an idea was eventually put into practice on
newly discovered, Earth-like worlds.
Numerous barren planets were intentionally
seeded with Earth species.
Isolated across lightyears of space, these
biospheres became home to spectacular forms
of new life.
This camo whale is a perfect example of how
strange life can get.
He hails our whale as he swims past, but the
youth only replies with fear.
The youngster is reaching a point of crisis.
His innate curiosity dulled, he no longer
finds joy in the unknown.
Even the dazzling bioluminescence of Lamplighter
fish yields no reaction.
But perhaps not all is lost.
Another youth has caught a Lamplighter, and
shows it off to our whale.
And for once, our whale doesn’t flee from
the encounter.
Instead, he seems excited to have made a new
acquaintance.
His sudden sociability is unexpected, but
it might have to do with the fact that young
whales can’t pass partner organisms to their
peers.
Whereas an adult could give him a permanent
symbiosis.
Perhaps all our whale really needed was a
friend he could be himself around.
The two whales spend the rest of the day in
each other’s company.
Night comes to the reef.
But our whale is up past his usual bedtime.
He’s out with a pod of other adolescent
Brillos.
They’re here for a rare spectacle.
Specks of light from Lamplighter fish illuminate
the nearby darkness.
This bold mating display makes them easy to
spot, but the Lamplighters don’t seem to
care about the young whales gobbling them
up.
It’s an example of a strategy known as ‘Predator
Satiation,’ where prey animals gather in
such high numbers, they know there’s a low
chance of them being eaten, so they let predators
have their fill.
Completely full and surrounded by glowing
lights, our whale appears truly happy to be
spending a night with friends.
A new dawn, seemingly the same as any other.
But today, the tide is particularly low.
There are all sorts of interesting things
in the shallows.
. . If one isn’t concerned about getting
stuck.
There’s no more time for exploring.
Trying to escape the dropping water level,
our whale becomes caught in the current of
the trenches.
One waterslide later, and he is unceremoniously
dumped into uncharted waters.
He’s now out past the Great Reef — a dangerous
yet intriguing prospect.
And he’s not alone.
Something is watching from within a nearby
cave.
It’s a solitary Brillo whale.
Our whale swims closer, although something
seems off.
This recluse has been exiled from the herd.
Banishment is rare in Brillo culture, and
was likely the result of a mating joust that
turned deadly.
Years of painful isolation has made him truly
dangerous.
Our Brillo says hello once more.
Still no response.
A helm made from a shark’s jaw indicates
the hermit’s fearsome might - but his secret
weapon hides in a watchtower atop his armor.
It’s a Vorpix Octopus, and it senses death
is on the menu.
He acts as the exile whale’s hunting partner.
Normally he’d assist in ensnaring prey,
but when the target is as helpless as our
whale, he prefers to watch.
Nothing like a front-row seat.
A strong emotion overpowers our whale.
Is it fear at last?
Evidently not.
Instead of fleeing, he’s playing and calling
to the exile as if he’s found a new friend.
But perhaps even more remarkably, the exile
isn’t attacking.
After decades of loneliness, this sudden compassion
seems to have profoundly moved him.
He strains to remember a Brillo song that
isn’t a menacing warning.
It’s not quite the show the octopus was
hoping to watch.
But he seems to have an idea.
At over four centuries old, this cephalopod
is highly intelligent, and knows a considerable
amount about Brillo biology.
Swimming closer, he offers our Brillo a piece
of the exile whale’s symbiotic armor plating.
One swift motion — and our whale’s life
is changed forever.
Now that he has bonded with a partner species,
over the coming years, our whale will change
in remarkable ways.
But for now, the first phase of the documentary
is complete.
When we next check in with our whale, he might
have metamorphized into something unrecognizable
— but that won’t be for quite some time.
That concludes all the chapters of “South
Scrimshaw” released so far.
But creator Nathan O. Marsh is planning more
entries in the future.
In the meantime, the full game is free to
play on Steam, which I’d highly recommend,
as the full experience contains more worldbuilding
details than this video could cover.
There are also links below to support the
creator directly and follow him on social
media.
As always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.